how did it all start how did Homo
sapiens
uh I'll compete the others the other
human-like species the Neanderthals and
the other
um homo species
you know and on the individual level as
far as we can tell we were not Superior
to them neanderthals actually had bigger
brains than us
and not just other human species other
animals too if you confirm me personally
to an elephant to a chimpanzee to a pig
I'm not so I I can do some things better
many other things worse if you put me
alone on some island with a chimpanzee
an elephant and a pig I wouldn't bet on
me being the the the the best Survivor
uh the the one that come comes is
successful if I may interrupt for a
second I just I was just talking
extensively with Elon Musk about the
difference between humans and chimps
relevant to Optimus the robot and uh The
Chimps
are not able to do this kind of pinching
okay with their fingers they can only do
this kind of pinching and this kind of
pinching is very useful for fine
manipulation about precise manipulation
of objects so don't be so hard on
yourself you have uh I said that I can
do some things better than a chimp but
you know if Elon musk's goes on a boxing
match with a chimpanzee
you know this won't help you this won't
help you against the chimpanzee good
point and similar if you want to climb a
tree if you want to do so many things my
bets will be on the chimp not on either
no fair enough so I mean you have
advantages on both sides
um and what really made us successful
what made us the rulers of the planet
and not the chimps and not the
Neanderthals is not any individual
ability but our Collective ability our
ability to cooperate flexibly in very
large numbers chimpanzees knows know how
to cooperate say 50 chimpanzees 100
chimpanzees as far as we can tell from
archaeological evidence this was also
the case with Neanderthals
uh Homo sapiens about 70 000 years ago
gained an amazing ability to be to
cooperate basically in unlimited numbers
you start seeing the formation of large
networks political commercial religious
um items being traded over thousands of
kilometers ideas being spread autistic
fashions
and and this is our secret of success
chimpanzees neanderthals can cooperate
say a hundred we you know now the global
trade network has 8 billion people like
what we eat what we wear it comes from
the other side of the world countries
like China like India they have 1.4
billion people even Israel which is a
relatively small country say 99 million
citizens that's more than the entire
population of the planet ten thousand
years ago of humans
so we can build these huge networks of
cooperation and everything we we've
accomplished as a species from you know
building the pyramids to flying to the
moon it's based on that and then you ask
okay so what makes it possible for
millions of people who don't know each
other to cooperate in a way that neander
tells our chimpanzees couldn't and at
least my answer is stories is fiction
it's the imagination if you examine any
large-scale human cooperation you always
find fiction as as its basis
it's a fictional story that holds lots
of strangers together it's most obvious
in cases like religion you know you
can't convince a group of chimpanzees to
come together to fight a war or build a
cathedral by promising to them if you do
that after you die you go to chimpanzee
heaven and you get lots of bananas and
coconuts no chimpanzee will ever believe
that humans believe these stories which
is why we have these huge religious
networks but it's the same thing with
modern politics it's the same thing with
economics people think oh economics this
is rational it has nothing to do with
fictional stories no money is the most
successful Story Ever Told much more
successful than any religious mythology
not everybody believes in God or in the
same God every but almost everybody
believes in money even though it's just
a figment of our imagination
you know you take these green pieces of
paper dollars they have no value you
can't eat them you can't drink them and
today most dollars are not even pieces
of paper they are just electronic
information passing between computers
we value them
just for one reason that you have the
best storytellers in the world
the bankers the finance ministers all
these people they are the best
storytellers ever
and they tell us a story that this green
little piece of paper or this bit of
information it is worth a banana and as
long as everybody believes it it works
so at which point does a fiction when
it's sufficiently useful and effective
and improving the global quality of life
does it become
like accept the reality like there's a
threshold which is just you know people
believe it it's like with money you know
if you start a new cryptocurrency if if
you're the only one that believes the
story I mean again you you
cryptocurrencies you have the math of
course but ultimately it's storytelling
you're selling people a story if nobody
believes your story
you don't have anything but if lots of
people believe the Bitcoin story then
Bitcoin can be worth thousands and tens
of thousands of dollars again why I mean
you can't eat it you can't drink it it's
nothing it's the story around the the
math which is the real magic
is it possible that the story is the
primary living organism not the
Storyteller
so
that somehow humans uh Homo sapiens
evolved to become these like hosts for a
more intelligent living organism which
is the idea and the ideas are the ones
that are doing the competing so this is
one of the
sort of big perspectives behind your
work that's really revolutionary how
you've seen history but do you ever kind
of uh take out the perspective of the
ideas as the organisms versus the humans
it's it's an interesting idea there are
two opposite things to say about it on
the one hand yes absolutely if you look
long term in history it's all the people
die it's the stories that compete and
survive and spread and stories often
spread by making people willing to
sacrifice sometimes their lives for the
story
um you know we know in Israel this is
one of the most important story
factories in human history and this is a
place where people still kill each other
every day over stories I don't know if
you've been to Jerusalem right so people
like Jerusalem Jerusalem Jerusalem you
go there I've lived in Jerusalem in much
of my life you go there it's an ordinary
place you know it's a town you have
buildings you have Stones you have trees
you have dogs and cats and pedestrians
it's a regular place
but then you have the stories about the
place oh this is the place where God
revealed himself this is the place where
Jesus was this is the place was Muhammad
was and it's the stories that people
fight over nobody is fighting over the
stones
people are fighting about the stories
about the stones
and the stories if if a story can get
millions of people to fight for it
um it not only survives it spreads it
can take over the world the other side
of the coin
is that the stories are not really alive
because they don't feel anything this
goes back to the question of
Consciousness which I think is the most
important thing that
the Ultimate Reality
is consciousness is the ability to feel
things if you want to know whether the
hero of some story is real or not
you need to ask can it suffer
um stories don't feel anything
countries which are also stories Nations
don't suffer if a nation loses a war it
doesn't suffer the soldiers suffer the
civilians suffer animals can suffer you
have an army with horses and whatever
and the horses get wounded the horses
suffer the nation can't suffer it's just
in a it's just an imagination it's just
a fictional story in our mind
he doesn't feel anything similarly when
a bank goes bankrupt or a company goes
bankrupt or when a a currency loses its
value like Bitcoin is worth now zero
crashed or the dollar is worth zero it
crashed the dollar doesn't feel anything
it's the people holding the dollars who
might be now very miserable
so we have this
complex situation when history is
largely driven by stories
but stories are not the Ultimate Reality
the Ultimate Reality is is feeling
feelings of humans of animals and the
tragedy of History
is it very very often we get it we get
the order wrong stories are not bad
stories are tools
they are good when we use them in order
to alleviate suffering
but very often we forget it
we instead of using the stories for our
purposes we allow the stories to use us
for their purposes and then you start in
tile Wars because of a story you inflict
Millions uh suffering on millions of
people just for the sake of a story and
that's the tragedy of human history so
the fundamental property of life
of a living organism is the capacity to
feel and the the ultimate feeling is
suffering you know to know if you're
happier or not it's a very difficult
question
yeah but when you suffer you know yes
and also in in ethical terms it's more
important to be aware of sufferings than
of any other emotion if you're doing
something which is causing all kinds of
emo all kinds of emotions to all kinds
of people first of all you need to
notice if you're causing a lot of
suffering to someone
if some people are like it and some
people are bothered by it and some
people are a bit angry in you and some
people are suffering because of what you
do you first of all have to know oh
now sometimes you still have to do it
you know the world is a complicated
place I don't know you have an epidemic
uh governments decide to have all that
social isolation regulations or whatever
so in certain cases yes you need to do
it even though it can cause tremendous
suffering but you need to be very aware
of the cost and to be very very you have
to ask yourself again and again and
again is it worth it is it still worth
it
and uh the interesting questionnaire
implied in your statements is that
suffering is a pretty good component of
a touring test for Consciousness this is
the most important thing to ask about AI
can can suffer because if
if I can suffer then it is an ethical
subject and it needs protection it needs
rights just like humans and animals well
quite a long time ago already so I work
with a lot of robots legged robots but
I've even had inspired by a YouTube
video I had a bunch of roombas and I
made them scream when I touched them or
kick them or when they run into a wall
and
the uh the illusion of suffering from
for me silly human anthropomorphizes
things is as powerful as suffering
itself I mean you you immediately
think the thing is suffering and I think
uh some of it is just a technical
problem but it's the easy easily
solvable one how to create an AI system
that just says please don't hurt me
please don't shut me off I miss you
uh where have you been be jealous also
what what where have you been gone for
so long your calendar doesn't have
anything on it so this kind of this this
create through words
the perception of uh of suffering of
jealousy of Anger of all those things
and it just seems like that's not so
difficult to do that's part of the
danger that um
it basically hacks our operating system
and it uses some of our best qualities
against us it's very very good that
humans are attuned to suffering and that
we don't want to cause suffering that we
have compassion that's one of the most
wonderful thing about humans and if we
now create AIS which use this to
manipulate us this is a terrible thing
you've kind of I think mentioned this uh
do you think it should be illegal
to to do these kinds of things with AI
to create the perception of
consciousness of saying please don't
leave me or sort of basically
um simulate some of the human-like
qualities yes I think again we have to
be very careful about it and uh and if
it if it emerges
spontaneously we need to be careful and
we can't rule out the possibility that
AI will develop Consciousness we don't
know enough about Consciousness to be
sure so if it develops spontaneously we
need to be uh uh to to
um be very careful about how we
understand it but if people
intentionally design an AI that they
know they assume it has no consciousness
but in order to manipulate people
they use again this human strength this
human uh the the noble part of our
nature against us this should be should
be forbidden and similarly a more
General level that it should be
forbidden for an AI to pretend to be a
human being
that it's okay you know there's so many
things we can use AIS as teachers as
doctors and so forth and it's good as
long as we know that we are interacting
with an AI we should the same way we ban
fake money we should ban fake humans
it's not just Banning deep fakes of
specific individuals
it's also Banning deep fake of generic
humans
you know which is already happening to
some extent on social media like if you
have lots of bots retweeting something
then you have the impression oh lots of
people are interested in that that's
important
and this is basically the Bots
pretending to be humans because if you
see a twit which says 500 people
retwitted it or you you see a a tweet
and it says 500 Bots which will delete I
don't care what the parts we created but
if it's humans okay that's that's
interesting so we need to be very
careful that Bots can't do that they are
doing it at present and it should be
banned now some people say yes but we
know of expression no Bots don't have
freedom of expression
there is no cost in terms of freedom of
expression when you ban Bots
so again in some situations yes AIS
should interact with us but it should be
very clear this is an AI talking to you
oh this is an AI retweeting this story
it is not a human being making a
conscious decision to push back on this
line of fake humans because I think it
might be a spectrum first of all you
might have ai systems that are offended
uh hurt when you say that they're fake
humans
um in fact they might start identifying
as humans and and you just talked about
the power of us humans with our
collective intelligence to take fake
stories and make them quite real
so if the feelings you have for the fake
human is real
uh you know love is a kind of fake thing
that we all kind of
put a word to a set of feelings what if
you have that feeling for an AI system
it starts to change
I mean maybe uh
the kind of things AI systems are
allowed to do for good they're allowed
to
uh create
communicate suffering communicate it the
good stuff the longing the the hope the
connection the intimacy all of that
um and in that way get integrated in our
society and then you start to ask a
question on
are we allowed to really unplug them are
we allowed to really censor them remove
them remove their voice I'm not saying
social media they shouldn't have a voice
they shouldn't talk with that I'm just
saying when they talk with us it should
be clear that they are AI
that's it don't you can have your voice
as an AI again I mean I I have some
medical problem I want to get advice
from an AI doctor that's fine as long as
I know that I'm talking with an AI that
what should be banned is AI pretending
to be a human being this is something
that will erode trust and without trust
Society collapses this is something that
especially will endanger democracies
because democracies are built on
Democracy is a conversation basically
and uh it's a conversation between
people
if you're not flood the public sphere
with millions and potentially billions
of AI agents that can hold conversations
they never sleep they never eat they
don't have emotions of their own they
can get to know you and tailor their
words specifically for you and your life
story they are uh becoming better than
us at creating stories and uh ideas and
so forth if you flood the Public's fair
with that this will ruin the
conversation between people it will ruin
the trust between people it's you will
no longer be able to have a democracy in
this situation you can have other types
of regimes but no democracy